du spielst du ekelig taktisch allerdings
vorne wie kann man da so abhetzen das
gibt's ja neulich musste ohne witz und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
woanders wollen heute wieder eine runde
firstfive und mein gegner am heutigen
tage ist
hallo hallo hallo nlp auch in der
beschreibung verlinkt wenn jährigen
wollte wie er sich so schlägt wären wir
gleich sehen wie spiele der firstfive
das heißt wir spielen bis einer first
was mich viel mit einer 5 wins in london
gemacht habe ich bin mein zufälligen
kids und wir springen in die erste von
der vorrunde numero nokia trotz das wird
ein richtiges wenn dem kind zweier durch
mittag aber wieder mal das comeback
starten wird dieses mal 45 mal auf die
schnauze
ben hat irgendwie skeptisch zu kriegen
nachdem wir dagegen wenig gesehen hat ja
du bist halbstark ich wusste schon immer
dass porsche lernmodus ja die klassische
doktor banks weglaufen taktik ich begab
mich zugerannt nie nein du rennst immer
weg geburt man muss das spiel was man
gut kann mein lieber fick dich nicht
gehen welt ist er ich sagte dass ich
dachte jungs ich hatte nämlich kein
wasser mehr als die winter den scheiß
noch in der lava stehen müsste hätte ich
mir aufsteigen müssen alte intense erste
runde hat jetzt wirklich vier minuten
gedauert
ich bin so kaputt jetzt schon
normalerweise dort ist eine video vier
minuten ok nächste runde
ich glaube das ist sogar dein eigenes
kind kann das ja ist das kartrennen cds
nicht oder doch
doch es habe ich in schwerin instant
aufgesammelt
ich hätte diesen abgleich herum zu
laufen denn immer mit dem bogen zu
zählen ich erkenne ich kenne ich die
mädels sehen
das wdr längst dahin bullshit alte was
als fünfter da kann doch doch ich habe
mir selbst wenig fläche maltesisches ort
beach
ja ich hätte man kann doch nicht
vergessen mahnt die ganze diese fehler
jetzt wo ich denke ich auf den goldabbau
drin paket bei dem kind habe ich ein
portabler in dem schon ein paar turniere
gespielt werden zeitnah die
mitverbrennung zu üben so schauen dass
ich wieder tore machen und wegklatschen
die ennahda der wagen steht ja gar nicht
so leute jetzt hier mit power an die
aula anti doktor banks geht es ist
beinahe aus ghana genau das was so gut
kann es ist immer ende ausgewählt wo man
mal nicht bleiben kann
ja es ist beendet klar ich meine ich hab
mich gefreut als das kam aber es war
gott mit anderen bränden vorderste auto
kicker jaja alter da war der speed weg
da ich hab's gesehen wetterlage anmache
wirkt so als ob man die werte dort ist
rastlos niemals also entweder gehe ich
gerade so komisch du bist schlecht
sollte sagen was los ist du standest du
hast mir ein hit gegeben auf einmal
rennst du so mit doppeltem speed auf
mich zu jaja altert aber der speed weg
das ist kein scheiß [ __ ] der aufnahme
nachschauen richtig selbst kann man eh
nichts runde
damit der angriff so rotter wieder 16
fälle kann ein bisschen baustellen
wieder abgeholt er wieder so krank ein
bisschen brauchst dann jedoch nur 16
aber die ganz locker ich sehe da der
fucking weinert ich bin hochgesprungen
im moment ja genau europe pvp olin
dopings alle so voll konzentriert ja da
wird nicht geredet man ich habe diese
scheiß halben zeit ich will ein für den
gold ab vergessen man nicht brechen
macht schon wieder nicht was willst du
nicht weißt nicht wo du bist gemeint
wieder hielt das maschinengewehr ich
habe keine ich habe keine freunde mich
genug zufriert täglich mit einer angel
leister anerkannter besser killer aus
killer aus ganz einfach gespielt so
ekelig taktisch anblicks 3 0 vorne wie
kann man da so abhetzen es gibt sehr
weich musste ich habe ohne witz traten
ich habe am ende hat ihre tricks 3 0
vorne da ist verlieren gerade macht
nicht in greifbarer nähe
es war knapp es war knapp ich dachte
dass jetzt wieder verpackt aber leute
der turnaround kommt 3 zu 1
nein ich wieder so eine scheiße das ist
zu billig heilungs außerdem lockt das
ist deine einstellung als warte mal ich
geb dir mal einen fall testen was zuviel
ist
weißt du doch etwas über gesucht habe
ich mit ihm aus rad gelegt habe dr banks
spam rhinow
er frisst als ich hier nichts da
inventar sortieren beim ausgang
elefanten richtig heftig
also deine leistung natürlich so krass
wie kannst du das fressen
wie kannst du diese schwert kompressen
niemals alter den kanal und ganz in
ordnung so aber das nachfüllen scheiße
habe ich verdrückt richtig gefehlt alter
davos ins inventar geöffnet zu suchen
heute kommt kommt komm lass mich in ruhe
die meisten stinkt ja komm der frist per
du kannst dich wie viel geld es gibt
sich zieht durch staub einfach steht ab
jetzt ja alter clark laura an wieder
junge autoclick alles drin wie du hast
du nicht ernsthaft wie fehlt in der zeit
oder noch what the [ __ ] wie hast du die
fehlbestand es höchstens mal eine
sekunde auf dem fleck ausgeht schon
schneller des post aber jetzt 0 rietveld
ich dachte du kannst auch nicht gefehlt
doch da auch ein paar sogar alter ich
habe ich hab gar nicht wieviel mich ein
einziges mal also das diner du hast mit
einer leiste ja mit einer leicht
modifizierten mir gemacht ich habe drei
ich habe drei oder vier leisten gehabt
wie hast du die combos gesehen nicht
gegeben habt das tablet locker doppelt
in der er dreimal
ich komme ich kann apple ich kann ich
wie viele leute das muss ich lernen und
hausrat gehabt wieder aber dafür auf
jeden fall dicker und nur halt dafür was
echte dafür war sehr gut nur ich habe
nicht gefehlt ok egal 41 nächste runde
kommt
so leute die finale runde es ist ein
gott das ist mein kind 64 fall
die bringt nix diesen diesen kaum
geklatscht
but a a
denkst du altersversicherung alte drei
tage später schon wie intense dieses
möchte dass leute schon gewesen
erdiger ich war konstant oder wie sie
etwa schon auf dem halben herzen
erzählen diese aufgabe doch zu krass
lange des gibt's aber ich werde sich 41
verpacken deswegen hat sich jetzt gab es
darum geht ein pfeil ist ein fall für
mich okay dann eben nicht
dann finden wir so viel ich wusste ja
ich hab gar keine mehr
hecht nicht wie krass dass nun gesperrt
hat
jetzt soll ein gauner alter methoden
nein
doch jetzt kommt mir aus kannst alles
geholt ich habe die scheiße geholt
mannheim
alle drei bisher als wird der facc ein
bogen habe ich ihn getroffen alter 24
leute nächstes kit aber sonntag ich kann
ich nehme die ersten die hier ankommen
nur die burschen hatten nämlich nicht
weiß es nicht gesagt du bist ja nicht
hinkommen muss wenn macht sein gegenüber
almer kompliment ich mit dem honig ums
maul um das zu packen
ich hab dir mehr hits gegeben das gibt's
doch nicht
da hat er irgendwie dort am anfang hast
du mir einen hit mehr gegeben und ich
habe ja am ende angehörige geben also so
dass wir am ende gleich viele zahlen
aber mein halbes helfen haben du hast
noch irgendwann kriegt reinbekommen mit
deinen dreckigen critics alter ist ich
hab schnell hinter gitter schnell auf y
gedrückt ich bin froh dass ich das einst
zu viel noch gedreht haben ist das
wichtigste eigentlich da habe ich
gezeigt was geht so danach natürlich der
unkonzentriert typische es kam
allerdings beim taktik drei runden lang
vom ergebnis her ein recht großer
unterschied zum 5 2 1 gegen wen ich aber
aber jetzt noch einmal gut gespielt die
erste ist unkonzentriert auf den fall
danke dass du dabei warst band wir sind
bei der nächsten folge wieder biss dann
haut rein macht's gut und